one of my First Reactions was pure
Terror that because I was so excited I
just became paranoid that I was going to
um somehow blurt out that I refuse the
fields mode or when obviously I wanted
to accept it so I think I had the most
bizarre response to his question that I
very very slowly and deliberately said
yes I accept the fields medal which is
the most surreal phrase
so certainly when I was in secondary
school I was aware of the concept of the
fields medal as a sort of
maths version of the Nobel Prize or
something I think the fields model was
the only maths surprise I was aware of
then I can't remember at all when the
first time I'd heard about the fields
medal would be but yeah it must have
been at some point when I was at school
not Goodwill Hunting that that's when I
first heard of it Goodwill Hunting made
the fields medal famous following you
around with the field smell the feels
metal
it's about my middle is it oh God I can
go home and get it for you can have it
yeah so it took me an embarrassingly
long period of time to watch Goodwill
Hunting I think so um despite the fact
I've been keen on Maths for such a long
time yeah somehow everyone else seemed
to have watched Goodwill Hunting but I
hadn't watched it so I didn't learn
about it from there so it's well
documented we've even spoke about it you
started having some successes and making
some impressive breakthroughs and people
started talking about you being a
contender for the fields medal I I used
to see on Reddit every time Fields medal
season came around your name would be
amongst the possible winners
did people ever talk to you about it
were people that did people ever say to
you James I reckon you could win it this
year like things like that were you very
aware of it so maybe a couple of
colleagues had loose comments uh and so
you made indications that they thought
it was possible but
um strangely
the biggest thing was that people didn't
talk about it that normally
mathematicians like to gossip a little
bit about Fields medals and things
um and so in some Cycles sort of when
we're just having uh dinner or if we're
having coffee or something together
people gossip about who might win a
Fields medal but it was notable that for
this cycle no one was talking to me
about the fields medal at all and I
seemed to be cut out of all the normal
gospin that was going on so in terms of
my interactions with colleagues it was
actually more than not talking to me
than them talking to me that uh was an
indication that they thought maybe I was
one of the candidates how did you find
out so
I was decorating my house so I was at
the top of ladder painting one of the
ceilings and I came down to have a break
and I checked my phone and then I had an
email from the IMU president saying
could we arrange a zoom call sometime
soon and I had a suspicion then as to
what it was I was desperately trying to
convince myself that he wanted me to be
on some boring committee and this was
nothing to get excited about at all
because I didn't want to get ahead of
myself
um but realistically that's when I had
the first sort of inclination that maybe
I'd run the fields medal and then we
organized this Zoom call in my office
unfortunately he was very kind and just
said basically straight up oh we've
decided to award you the fields medal so
it cut all the tension out pretty
quickly what was your first feeling do
you remember what first went through
your head
um obviously I was ecstatic the IMU
president asks you
um will you accept the fields medal
because I guess there's this notable
case with Parliament that he declined
the fields medal so in fact
one of my First Reactions was pure
Terror that because I was so excited I
just became paranoid that I was going to
somehow blurt out that I refuse the
fields mode or when obviously I wanted
to accept it so I think I had the most
bizarre response to his question that I
very very slowly and deliberately said
yes I accept the fields medal which is
the most surreal phrase
um that I think I said because I was
just completely terrified that somehow
I'd been awarded the fields medal and I
would accidentally reject the fields
Meadow
okay well done for not rejecting it uh
what's the chat like then does he tell
you obviously he tells you some
procedural things are you sworn to
secrecy what's the deal at this point
um yeah they give you
um he said that he taught me through a
few of the basic procedural things and
then there's a number of extra details
that go through uh they strongly ask you
to keep it secret secret they understand
that you'll tell a couple of very close
um family members and maybe a couple of
close colleagues
um but uh they're very very keen to keep
it as secret as possible because
naturally that's part of the um final of
these Awards
the fields there's obviously other
people who win the fields medal do they
tell you the other winners at that point
or do you not know who your sort of
colleagues are at that stage no so I
only knew for sure who the other winners
were when I walked into the backstage
room in Helsinki right before the fields
medal ceremony I was certainly trying to
sort of guess from other things and you
talk to some journalists
um so I think I had heard from one of
the journalists that I was the youngest
Fields medalist because the journalists
obviously know the other ones
um but yeah I only knew for sure who the
other ones were when I was backstage and
I recognized the other people so when
you got off that call who did you tell
funnily enough
this was in the early evening and I'd
arranged to meet a group of
mathematicians in the pub and so I went
straight off to the pub because I was
already a bit late to meet them but I
had to keep myself very quiet and not
tell anyone so I had this very awkward
period of like socializing with some
other mathematicians and just having
chats about different things so they're
like why are you late James and you're
like oh sorry I was just winning a
Fields medal yeah so I made up some
rubbish excuse about like getting
distracted and getting too into my maths
and something running over
um and I was desperately trying to sort
of not have a big beaming smile the
entire time and to just talk about other
things so the fields medal is always
normally given at the international
conquest of mathematicians this was uh
due to be held in Russia um in Saint
Petersburg but because of the war in
Ukraine it was decided that this was not
feasible for obvious reasons and so
there was a somewhat last minute switch
to Helsinki and most of the
international Congress was then held
online but they had an in-person
ceremony for the awarding of the fields
medals
in housing care along with the initial
talks and the opening ceremony you go
backstage watch some green room or
something and that's when you first see
the other winners yeah that's right
um uh yeah so I'm there in my suit
feeling super nervous and I go backstage
and there's all the other winners and
um I think everyone is sort of super
nervous and being a bit quiet and then
uh Hugo Domino copper comes in and he's
exceptionally Lively and he starts
chatting to people and he breaks the ice
and then suddenly everyone's chatting to
everyone else and I think that was great
because it calm my nerves an awful lot
did you know the three others like to
recognize them or
um I visually recognize them yeah so I
had maybe
seen one or two of them before in person
but I basically hadn't seen them in
person when I didn't know them
personally but I knew who they were and
I recognized them from photos I'd seen
did you know any much about their
mathematics
um
I knew a little bit about uh most of the
mathematics yeah I'd heard about some of
the sort of main results that they'd had
I sometimes look at these lists of four
yearly winners that these clusters I
always think you're kind of you're
you're all bonded now aren't you like
that you're you're a little class do you
feel a bond with them
um I certainly feel a bit of a bond with
them yeah I mean it's not like we've had
any uh extra comment to it's not we
don't have a 2022 Fields medalists
WhatsApp group or anything like that
um but uh yeah there's a certain amount
of camaraderie that uh you know it was a
very important time in my life and they
were all going through exactly the same
thing and exactly the same time
brilliant and what happens at the
ceremony did you have to make a speech
do you just take your medal and walk off
the stage how does the procedure go so
there's the award ceremony initially
where I just take my medal then there's
another distinguished mathematician in
the area who gives a sort of
presentation on each of the Winner's
works but that's all I have to do for um
that first day and then in the second
day I give a lecture Associated to
winning the fields medal so then you've
got it you know you bring it home we'll
look at it in a minute hopefully there
it is I can't wait to see it but
um
like what next like it's kind of like I
know there are some other big prizes in
mathematics now like big big prizes but
the fields medal still seems to be like
the Nobel Prize one is there is there a
feeling at all of
hmm now what like that's like that this
could be the biggest thing I ever win
yeah it's only downhill from here
um
I mean I think most mathematicians are
kind of really motivated by mathematics
and so
um
I'm completely ecstatic and Overjoyed
that I've won the fields medal uh but
you know the thing that's always driven
me is understanding kind of Truth in
mathematics and getting to the heart of
um kind of mathematical puzzles and
things like that
um and the sort of real satisfaction
um is from when I prove ethereum that I
really like I get this immense Joy from
that and so that's still what drives me
on and that's what drove me initially
and that hasn't changed at all so
um I hope that I can keep my feet on the
ground and not get too full of myself or
anything like that and to just continue
being a research mathematician who's
driven by trying to understand research
mathematics yeah so the fields medal is
only awarded once every four years and
it's only awarded to mathematicians who
are under the age of 40. so it's very
much only given to Young mathematicians
I think originally the this was intended
to be a prize for promising young
mathematicians as an encouragement but
just for historical reasons
the people who've won it has led to
becoming a much more prestigious award
than maybe it was ever originally
intended to be
and so there's now this odd status that
one at least one of the very Premier
prizes in mathematics has this very very
young age limit yeah I feel that there's
obvious benefits and disadvantages that
um on some level I sometimes find it a
little bit
dissatisfying that Nobel prizes are
given to people really right at the end
of their career often they've been
retired for a long period of time
and so it's not selecting the sort of
most exciting work and the people who
you're expecting to come up with the
next breakthroughs and that's one nice
thing about the fields medal that it is
choosing very promising and talented
young mathematicians
um and people who are therefore maybe
amongst the people who might be making
the next set of breakthroughs you can
and you can use the benefit of it some
of those little doors that opens and
advantages it gives you you can use
while you're still practicing uh yeah
exactly so that's certainly one benefit
of the Phil's medal obviously a big
disadvantage is that the relatively low
age limit
has a certain distorting effect that
different education systems accelerate
people to different extents and so
afford your cutoff is quite arbitrary
people who have to do military service
at disadvantages people who maybe take
career breaks because of caring
responsibilities or having children or
things like that it's sort of slightly
unfairly disadvantages
the fact that it's just once every four
years with this age limit means that uh
what year you're born mod 4 has a
Advantage as to whether you have more
possible research time to make
contributions or not so it has lots of
sort of slightly undesirable effects
like this as well yeah if you solve the
Riemann hypothesis as a 41 year old too
bad yeah exactly but if you'd somehow
just been born one year earlier then
everything would have been fine
um can I please see the medal you can be
so this is my medal it comes in that
case does it yeah it came in this case
what was it like when they handed it to
you was it what did that feel like
um I mean I think I was in a daze the
entire time uh through the ceremony so
um everything felt amazing and I was
just on cloud nine but I was also
slightly unaware of everything that was
going on
did any of your family come over to
Helsinki no you see the
strange thing was that
um I was awarded my medal on the 5th of
July but my first son was going to be
born on the 7th of July so
um I received the medal on the 5th on
the morning of the 6th I gave my talk
Associated to the fields medal normally
they give the talks in alphabetical
order but they changed the order because
I needed to get back to the UK from
Finland and I flew straight back to the
UK after given the first talk in the
morning
um and then in the morning of the 7th of
July my first son was born so that was a
it's going to be difficult to top that
week yeah
brilliant and the last question I have
is what do you do with it like where
like what do you do with the middle do
you ever look at it does it have a pride
of place is it locked in a safe or like
you know as much as you can tell us yeah
so this is one of the slightly
disappointing things I guess that
because it is sort of valuable both
sentimentally but also I think the medal
itself is gold and so has some value
value I sort of have it locked in a box
at home which means I don't actually see
it very often it's just sort of locked
in a Cupboard somewhere and so in some
ways it's a bit silly that I win this
medal that I'm super proud of I really
like but rather than show it off or look
at it it just gets put in the cupboard
a longer version of this interview can
be found on our number File 2 Channel
and I've also turned that extended
version into an episode of the number
file podcast you'll find that in all the
usual podcast places
Plus for more videos with James Maynard
and an assortment of other fields
medalists check out links in the video
description
[Music]
this episode was supported by brilliant
makers of fantastic online courses and
puzzles and quizzes like the ones you're
looking at right now
now no doubt these are a workout for
your brain covering all manner of
mathematics computer science and just
science in general but it's not just
telling you stuff talking down to you
these are courses that you interact with
and one of my favorite things about
brilliant is sometimes it's funny it has
personality it's made by people with
smiles on their faces you can tell
this is just fantastic stuff it's so
much fun
and now brilliant has a 30-day free
trial so there's another reason to go
and have a look go to brilliant.org
number file for the trial but that
code's also going to get you 20 off
their annual plan check them out people
it's clever it's quirky
rings
hello
and the voice was saying hello this is
lazlovas from Budapest and then my heart
skipped a bit see whether you're living
in an even dimensional space or odd
dimensional space